just hilarity and goodwill last night in
uh denver huh
markeith morris with the shot to nicola
jokic and the joker with the shot in the
back to markeith morris
i love this and both
ejected
no word on a suspension yet so which one
you're going to spend
well it could be both people well you
want to because it's been one of them
you got to spend both of them you can't
suspend the joker i'm just saying
you can't suspend the joker you cannot
without suspenders without spinning bars
tony no okay i'm just saying you're
that's your
you're saying they both should they both
be suspended
one game yes yes probably one game
because of the because because of the
letter of the law of the nba but i like
what the joker but if there wasn't a
letter of the law you're okay with what
with what joker did wait hold on i don't
know what to do no i'm just saying what
did joker do hold on
i gave him a shot in the back and
whiplashed him no no hold on
did he not get him shaq ernie did he not
ernie it's called retaliation i know
what it is first of all when you hit me
don't turn around
don't turn around brad miller because
i'm swinging don't you not turn around
you're either going to take it in the
front or taking the back as a big guy
when when a little guy hits you you
gotta touch on my back i have no problem
with what the joker did i actually like
it as a big guy you got these guys foul
on you hanging on he hit him
unintentionally i mean
intentional unnecessary roughness so
what do you do as a big guy you go hit
him back when you hit me don't turn your
head because it's coming you're either
going to get in the front or you're
going to get it in the back
was was that a dangerous and dirty play
no exposure is just wrong he's just
defending this guy
ernie
i'm watching all these fools on
television all day talk about this
i was like well first of all mars
started it let's get first
joker retaliated and then people say
well he hit him in the back well if you
hit me i would shack on it let me tell
you something ernie if you hit me you
better not turn your damn back because
i'm coming back at you you can't hit
somebody and turn your back
you just that's like kenny it's the most
mild-mannered nice dude in the world if
somebody hit him are we swinging we
swinging are we swinging we i i think
we would hope that joker could have some
self-restraint
himself said he shouldn't have reacted
no no wait i'm just saying i'm not
saying that we no don't wait let me
finish go ahead i i we would hope
however
because of who he is
the position he plays
and what guys are trying to do and send
what message they're trying to send he
sent the biggest message so the message
is we used to say that about blake
griffin guys were following blake
griffin back in the day when he was
flying through the air dunking on people
or they're trying to send a message to
him to stop flying through the air
joker's like no no no the message is if
i fly through here you're going to get
hit now so now we're going to just play
basketball i just remember a story kevin
mchale said to me one time he when he
was playing the pistons he said
you know they would they would ban beer
and they were beating them up he says
eventually we're gonna have to play
basketball and i'm gonna kick your ass
and so
we got to get it back to basketball
otherwise everyone would try to do that
to him that's the plan you know we
always say
uh
what about what mars did was a
basketball play oh none zero zero and i
don't know what listen we all love sport
and he gonna defend this guy there was
nothing basketball related about what he
did to joker yeah but as a basketball
guy you have to let these little guys
know that hey you can foul me but if you
if you go over the line i'm coming back
at you you're right as a leader he's
supposed to come out and say hey it was
a wrong thing to do because
they're going to fire like that but
every now and then when somebody goes
overboard you have to you have to you
know return the message like kenny said
and let them know like hey i'm not going
to tolerate this jeremy do we have the
social media exchange
yeah let's because this has been this
has been uh something that the day after
uh marcus morris has waited until bro
turn back
noted okay all right
the gokitch brothers
they and they started their feed just
for this instead of publicly threatening
our brother your brother made a dirty
play first if you want to make a step
further be sure we will be waiting for
you the jokic brothers marcus you got
that right i want to believe that um
i believe i know that yeah and then
mama said don't talk on social media no
more well there you have it i love you
mama may 19th